do you want a hand he'll make into one
other level they like their my training
I'll tell me the two level you're super
bitter but everyone a third one there I
goodness is what the cameras that goes
over the room um um i'll do i'll do a
leveller i can't i can't guarantee that
I'll remember to hold up a bare hand
held by can help anybody yes yes thank
already already ok so now how do i
connect with kinect just put that your
shirt rather oh mo more questioning kick
you guys into the wine by the woods ok
thank you sure to thank you
did we don't
brand new technology
looks like it's google Tom groceries
where's google the third birthday yeah
this is this will be fine fine I mean
she is another
now what kind of talk together here
longer guarantee I will
do
sure that anything what's huh what's
that you got another would you would you
what are you what you looking for
working for did you wait to go yeah yeah
okay we like that involve walking
clearly I
is that
here in Italy where
yeah bang bang club and I eat
what I eat go find a Dunkin and rebel
there
I
this is a two years fingers I don't
think it was a solution
there's a gram change to the mark be
able to talk about emulating
okay this is interesting I'm not sure
what would he send addresses are those
who those huh oh okay great okay well in
that case I should I should figure out
how to stop doing whatever i'm john okay
okay you do your thang your thing
ok I think we're
no usually who's hiding this is small
maybe
Oh
cool
alright
there
sure skillet over Hillary check out so
thank you very much for the introduction
watching and thank you all for coming
out I'm really excited to be here here
this is lovely so for those of you who
don't know me my name is David gold sold
I am a PhD students in the department of
statistics six at the University of
Washington and ostensibly when I'm not
doing Julia development I am supposed to
be working with Johannes lederer to
develop estimators and in France
methodology for high dimensional models
and I got started our program in your
julia and kind of start programming in
general about a year and a half ago when
through this interesting confluence of
events i worked on nullable arrays dodge
al for a julia summer of code project at
the Wreckers Arthur which actually uses
that office over there to host speakers
and give seminars so it's pretty cool to
be back here on in the ebay offices and
okay about this talk talk there are two
you two main threads that I'm going to
go over the first describes my work with
summer at Julia labs MIT developing this
package structure oh yeah I wrote a blog
post that's far too wrong about it and I
found here I'll make slides available so
you can go check it out out and also
we're talking a little bit more about
tabular data support court in Julia
slightly more generally in particular
i'll be talking about some changes that
are coming to data frames and how the
that I don't I've done this past summer
and they're continuing to do please in
with it than that Matt and the main
takeaway is that there are fixing starts
I think with with data frames in Julia
but on the whole we're making progress i
decided to be a part of it i'm excited
for where it's going going and look
forward to what we have for when Julie
at one point I was released so a note
note everything that follows the subject
of change this is describing my work in
progress and I'm one of the reasons why
I was really excited to give this talk
is because I would love look back
everybody in the audience everybody
who's watching just if you have thoughts
about things that you see things that
you think could be improved I'm all ears
supposed to hear it you're it also so I
realized I left and steeped in all this
for the past however many months and so
there's anything that's unclear to you
because I think it might be assuming
certain zacchara that's not generally
had please raise your hand and ask a
question i'll be happy to entertain the
stranger and after the talk talk okay so
so what is structured queries it is a
package whose goals to represent or the
structure of a query with a directed by
a cyclical graph object and by query I
merely mean queries reason sequel or
just a series of use emulations you
should like to data as in as deep liar
liar and so big question why would you
want to do something like this and i
facetiously listed and cross about ten
reasons why you might want to want to
one everybody's looking guy exact right
they're all the rage shall we should use
in Cairo to second looking daj are my
initials and I'm a narcissist neither of
those two points are hopefully true true
the real reason why we might be
interested in such a project is because
representing the query with a
a graphical a graphic Jack Jack allows
us to make queries generic over multiple
back asked first and foremost we can get
compile potent quote those queries or
those objects X down to Julia code for
dealing in memory jewelry tables or we
can generate a sequel from them them for
instance and as far as the Julia table
support goes there are interesting
things we can do with a query framework
that represents queries are stressed
lately in order to solve a couple of
problems that have been plaguing the
data frames in general for I think years
so I'll talk more about that later on
and they have to do with typing for a
bill ability and now the data frames is
going to my built on top of militant
elbow races how do you solve lifting
this problem how to solve a problem of
making the oatmeal's usable so I'll talk
about God is tails too so an example of
what this package is about that so
suppose you consider the much belabored
iris dataset and we can load into data
frames as such using such a goo in this
very heavy and data streams to CSUN
sacrifices which are also awesome so we
have this I radula SATA set it is a days
of rain frame I will note that i am
using data frames master right now and
that is reflexive transition to
switching to nullable arrays as back in
support for data frame column so if you
want to play with this I welcome home to
I've tried to design this just your
notebook in such a way that you can just
just run things and follow prompts on to
follow along but do so at your own risk
risk ok so we have this data set is that
suppose we want to restrict it to Rose
loses value for a certain fields a
simple length is greater than 7.55 how
do we do that well in the native API I
for data frames one way to do this is
Phi index into the data frame with a a
column of zeros and ones that we can
generate by broadcasting this predicate
greater than 7.5 I've over the Colin
iris
sepal length length and this works it's
it has its ups and downs for 11 it's
nice not to have to write iris over and
over and over and more predicate that
you get the more time to write iris it
relies on broadcasted operators so it's
not it's a bit more accessible now that
we have the cup size broadcasting syntax
but still be nice to be able to just
work in terms of scalar operators if
that's what you want to do do you
there's another package data frames meta
which is kind of pioneering approach to
data manipulation nation with data
frames using macros I won't won't talk
too much about this but this would be
the solution to this particular data
manipulation problem album using data
frames meta so it's it's a nice concise
syntax you don't have to repeat iris
over and over it does rely on
broadcasted operators and it's all so
tightly coupled to the data frames
implementation so it's not generic for
multiple back actions in structured
queries what what I've done is offered
this provided this very merry grow grow
so using ariary you can create this
context where you can describe a series
of relation to data and the result of
this is a query object that wraps a
graphical structure or a graphical
representation nation of your query so
you see we use as ariary with this very
familiar filter syntax and we are
returned to query object and you can
expect the graphic that query by calling
graph RAF and the graph says okay we
have this node that represents the
filtering operation and input into that
note or fed them to that node is just
just a data source okay okay cool well
now what do I do with my query once I do
I take it for walks do I think it what
do i what do i do with a hurry hurry so
one thing you can do with the queries
extended to produce more queries so if
you query a query that will extend it
you can see that we can can add an
additional select operation to it by
using the same syntax the queria ver gap
the app carrieri mac raza supports
piping for readability and we see if
produces a new query airy that whose
graph a now reflects the fact that we
have asked his projection two new
species and pedal little would you can
use this composability of queries in
conjunction with functions and that in
that is nice play much of a rising
libraries so you can decide you can you
can use this to query or you could you
or produce a query that can be collected
against different decades I won't get
into that too much much and skip ahead
and said to the exciting yes yes
so the question is if I may paraphrase
what it is are there is there a
well-defined sets of back act for which
which this just query framework will
work and not worth work I want to break
that at that or my answer to that within
two parts and we're kind of coming to
this is the query framework itself can
be applied to do anything thing so you
can represent a barrier against anything
thing but then then the question of if
you try to collect the query against
anything will that work work is a
separate appointment so you can query or
anything and collect against anything
for which there is some support work so
if you're asking in principle does there
need to be in principle in principle
there aren't really any restrictions
other than data sources for which it
would make sense to represent such
queries against
so okay okay so the obvious use cases
que pase tabular data structure is part
of what's nice about this syntax about
this interface is that at you can talk a
wreck right about attributes of a tape
of the table so for instance here here
we are not we don't need to refer to
iris more than once we can just say
we're talking about iris that creates an
environment which we can talk about out
the absence of this table in general
there's no reason why such a framework
and support a more link like
functionality in which you can just just
say okay I have an iterator and now I
want to talk about elements of this
iterator and specify manipulations in
terms of these elements and then define
some semantics for collecting such as
very Airy so part of my answer to this
question is is the query framework in
the collections framework are decoupled
in the sense that the query framework is
designed to just represent a fiery area
and then it's up to somebody to
implement something inning and decide
what are the semantics that make sense
here here what does it mean to say they
select a little bit from iris well in
the case of the table that's fairly
straightforward but you could imagine
more exotic data structures where you
might have had multiple semantics that
would no sense 4 filtered ultimate okay
and did you have a question motion
okay okay
where
we all get to that so the question is
what sort of minute manipulations to say
attributes like super line can pedal
with with can you apply and I hope that
will become clear shortly and if not
please ask again again okay okay so this
is kind of a thing getting to art art no
no this is kind of pardon what is your
name sir Sir Geoffrey I think I think
this is I hope getting to Geoffrey's
question so I've shown you can extend
authority by burying against again I'll
throw out that I understand what the
word query is kind of one of those words
that once you repeat it over and over it
starts to lose its meaning and I
appreciate all of your bearing with me
of me you can also as you would hope to
be able to do materialize barrier as
some memory Julia object and the way
that I that I've designed mine that
framework to work is by using collect
liked so here we go to collect you the
query that really incidents on Stan
cheated earlier against iris and we see
we don't have a there's no back and
support yet for that specified live we
have to unload some package gauge that
decide that provides I'm antics for what
it means to collect such a barrier again
against a table link irises so there's
another package that is unregistered and
is tentatively Nations collect and it
does just that so we load this package
this package has a well the line
semantics rule gives a well-defined
semantics to collecting a query against
a a table like iris and it does is what
exactly what you would expect it to it
returns all the rows for which was
predicated satisfied
right so this is a collect machinery the
thing that makes collecting this query
against our online is defined in terms
of a abstract table type which has its
own interface in any object satisfying
this interface will then get support for
queries against or support for query
collection against subtypes so this is
the question for anybody who can hear
that before was what sorts of what sorts
of types are yes what is the scope Oh
types again for which collection in such
collection of support is is just data
frames other internet marry Julia table
objects and the answer is right now it's
only thing that satisfies the search
interface which is the subject for
another talk
would you repeat the question that's
true i'm totally hot open to that I'm
100-percent open to that that makes a
lot of sense I'm entirely open to the
naming suggestions I I don't claim to
excel on that point okay so whatever the
package name is it will be structured in
such a way so that you don't have to
load more than one package just load one
package whatever collection machine you
are using will we export this query
interface and everything would just be
simple for the user there's also a
convenience macro at collect which does
collection and burying in a single go so
you don't have to Clary and then collect
which is nice for in memory of tabular
data structures like data frames with
things that don't necessarily fit in
memory it's nice to have this layer of
Aquarion first I thinking so I don't
want to get into the weeds too much but
I think this is kind of important before
we talking looking for a report of work
part of the talk if we get to it at
there's time I'm about it just tabular
frameworks on Julie in general and the
main point that I want to stress here is
that both is that this is this selection
machinery works by essentially
transforming a data frame into an
iterator over tuples and then same
atkins predicate over those two pools so
really what we need is we need fast
iteration from a data frame that's
really important to making data
manipulation and julia work
that's a good question and it's
something that I have so the question is
it does how does Roe versus column
precedence influence or impact
performance and that's a really good
question that I is that without the
inaccurate and that's really the
question that I haven't explored yet
so Thomas point is that if I understand
it correctly is that suppose you only
want to end up projecting onto two
columns from a date from a data frame
that has like ten thousand columns you
don't want to zip together ten thousand
columns or any more numb anymore than
the columns that you'll need and
currently that optimization is in the
partner collection machinery but it's
certainly something that I've thought
about and I in tendency to implement it
include that's a good point
so the way I understand it is i think if
i'm understanding jeffries collection or
a question collection question too many
too many keys and right exactly if i'm
understanding Jeffrey's clear acrylic
correctly this has to do with so when
we're performing these sorts of
operations does it help to have a
kilometer or a row wise memory layout is
that yeah and so it's all it's about a
memory layout of the data and the
question is there so we have two
possible memory layouts which one's
better for these sorts of operations and
the answers I don't know the columns
together you're assisting so you're
zipping in general takes to iterate yeah
and so you're sitting just columns and
then when we iterate over that results
in zipper is this iterative you get
tuples that are elements of the data
frame just as rose all right you are so
I don't want to get too into the weeks
here the main the main thing and I'm
having to talk about this afterwards I
want to go a little bit further but the
main point takeaway is that if we're
going to make any of this worthwhile we
need fast iteration over to tools that
are somehow generated from a data frame
this is just these slides are just about
show just show how all the things that
we need for doing this operation than
the filtering predicate and some other
things are stored in the query graph
itself so this is this graph right here
is not just as pretty printing of the
query it also holds all the information
that we need all the data that we need
in order to conduct the query by
integrating over rows as the data frame
so once we get that raft straightened
out and have all of those all that data
we need in there it's more or less just
a matter
extracting it in a systematic fashion
and iterating over rows from a data
frame so I mentioned the whole one of
the points of this is to be back in dec
Gnostic that's actually not something
that I've so much been focused on but ye
zijn at the at MIT in the department of
operations research has been doing some
cool work on this and I direct you all
to his package sequel query in
particular this pull request in which we
are working together to make his query
translation or his translation of these
queria graphs into sequel a reality that
is unfortunately the most i will say
about translation into sequel at this
point in time but i'm happy to entertain
questions about it later
one would hope I don't hook but I all
have to thank you ok so we've shown
built using this Koree framework to
filter what else can I do with this what
other commands are supported so you can
this is speaking to I'm sorry I didn't
catch your name was it Graydon so great
and asked earlier what sorts of
transformations can we cite inside of
the query and so hopefully this gives
you some sort of a sense and it's
basically arbitrary our operations you
can multiply columns by two you can take
ty gamma the log of something and I
don't know why you'd want to but you can
I don't have support for control flow in
there yet you can use if else but things
like ternary operator won't work but
there's no reason in principle why that
could be there's no reason why in
principle any Julia code couldn't become
part of a say a scalar transformation
that you operate that you apply row by
row
sure I mean that's what that gamma and
log are there they're no different than
user defined functions the question is
could you define your own user function
f of whatever and apply it inside of the
query and the answer is absolutely
absolutely so there's also support for
grouping and aggregation if you vote if
you all have ever used deep liar this
syntax will be very familiar to you the
the printing is not quite as pretty
because what happens when you group a
data frame or any in-memory julia
tabular data object that satisfies the
interface that the collection machinery
is built off of it wraps that object in
this grouped wrapper which holds index
information about which row observations
fall into which groups and there's just
not pretty HTML printing for such a
thing but as you can see you can group
by and then apply aggregating functions
over the group and there's no set list
of aggregating functions that work and
don't work it's just anything that maps
a column to a scalar you can safely
apply and it will do the right thing in
principle joins there is basic support
for inter joins so we have one day to
frame you make another data frame we
join them together on a1 equals a to
there's also support for joining on more
complex equal joins so for instance we
can say a you know join on a1 equals
this predicate of B of B to
and right now the implementation of
joins only supports equity but of course
I hope to expand that in the near future
so issues and to dues so one thing is
named resolution which I didn't really
talk about too much in the previous
slides but as you as you can see names
inside of a query are assumed to be at
this point fields of a tabular data
object which going back to Jeffrey's
point is not entirely general as far as
the sorts of things that could become a
quare become the object of a query it
also kind of messes up name resolution a
little bit because the general pattern
is functions that are called within a
manipulation verb like summarize for
instance those are parsed or those are
those are inherited from the enclosing
scope so we inherit reduce from the
enclosing scope because it's a function
that's being called on objects sepal
length is an argument to a function or
rather it's just something that's not
being it's not it's not a function
column so it's assumed to be a field
inside of a table and that's parsed
correctly but then plus which is not a
field of the iris table it still parse
to be a field of the irish table so
that's wrong so you couldn't do this as
such this naive query would not give you
the right thing you would have to
interpolate in this symbol to make sure
that this querying framework knows that
plus isn't the app isn't an attribute of
some table it's a it's a name from the
enclosing scope conversely if you had a
column of functions and you wanted to do
say select f of a where f is the name of
that app is the name of that column of
functions that wouldn't parse Clark
correctly it would look for f in the
enclosing scope as opposed to as the as
opposed to looking for it as an
attribute of the table so both of those
things are unsatisfactory and they can
be a solve with some sort of
epilation syntax but it's it kind of
rubs me the wrong way to say that
sometimes names of functions are parsed
correctly and sometimes or sometimes
they're parsed as from the enclosing
scope and sometimes they're parsed as
attributes of a table I'm not super fond
to that I hope that they're I I would
like there to be a solution that doesn't
involve that so so that's one issue it
relates to what I list down here
interpolation soft parametrized queries
I'll kind of skip that and then
implementation wise make everything fast
make everything better there's this
really cool Jamie Brandon wrote a really
cool blog post about a really
interesting project in which he
demonstrates that you can write a very
performant relational query compiler
entirely in Julia so why not do that
that should be something like that
there's no reason something like that
should be driving querying against the
data frame to the best of our abilities
say again
one finds one just follows these links
which I which I'll make available but if
you want to if you if you if you're in
yeah goodness go go to scattered
thoughts dotnet and I think as a right
scattered dash thoughts net and I
believe as of right now the write up
about his relational query compiler will
be the second blog post mm-hmm my
pleasure I budget by you know I think
there's definitely not you so on this
point is well in for instance data
frames meta you prefix attributes with
colons in other words you somehow
designate what names in the industry of
your query are supposed to refer to
attributes of a table I think that's
actually a good idea i think you know in
deep liar you don't do that a deeper has
delayed evaluation on its side so we can
actually tell what's the name of from a
table and that's not we can't i was the
original pot was makes something that's
entirely as convenient as deep liar but
if it introduces these weird rules or
inconsistencies then maybe it's not as
convenient and it's time to go back to
something that forces you to designate
well it's an attribute and what's not
is we have abilities yet Colin's
literally be careful yeah so I mean
there are no easy answers here to trade
offers of convenience versus consistency
in name resolution it's not yet really
clear to me what is going to be most
important individually a data science
world I don't think you don't have
enough you know coming up data points
where are the benchmarks shifty eyes
face and I know show so the answer is I
don't I don't have benchmarks here and I
know that's showing up to a Julia meet
up without benchmarks is like showing up
to a party without I guess I was going
to say I am a graduate student so I
don't go to parties but yes they're like
here's the obvious fall back it's like
showing up to a party up here but it
will say is that at this point in the
development of this collection machinery
the main thing that I was interested in
is just getting something that's type
type inferable all right at a minimum to
write for our Julia code to be
performing it needs to be type inferable
and in this case that means that
iteration over whatever is generating
our couples of Rose needs to be a type
in verbal and there's some preliminary
work in John miles White's notes way
back from the beginning of the summer
the show that this is the case and if
you actually go and inspect the code you
know throw at at code warned type in
various places in the implementation it
will show that indeed the parts of the
code that we want to be typing verbal
our type and verbal and so that gets us
at least the first step towards the most
Foreman implementation of course whether
we can afterwards all right there's a
lot of stuff that for instance jaime
bergman was worrying about in his
project which is getting Julia to
produce really efficient code in terms
of what what gets boxed what doesn't hit
box what other or not closures are
typing or whether or not names from
closures are type inferable and whatnot
and as those are a lot of subtleties
that I hadn't gotten too and that are
yes complicated pushing liability but
I'm excited to go and look at them more
closely so long story short on
performance we've checked off the first
box there are more boxes to check off
before it's worth while making
interesting comparisons so there were
comments there are comments about the
interface in about name resolution about
mostly by name resolution and that's
something that I've been thinking a lot
about late lately are also comments
about what sorts of objects does it make
sense to carry and the interfaces art is
the interface as part of that if
interface assumes makes assumptions
about this structure of your data in
terms of whether or not it has
attributes then arguably that restricts
the set of things that you can vary with
it so I thought about those issues and
and I've been working on a new interface
or a revised interface and I suppose
makes obsolete everything that I've just
shown you so I don't know if that was a
really good idea but I mean part of part
I mean part of why I am keeping this
presentation is because I genuinely want
feedback this isn't all a sure thing you
know you can tell me I like the old one
better I like the new one better I hope
that you all will help me steer the
direction of this interface so without
further ado
this is what it looks like so we have a
data frame and it relies on this this
with macro and it kind of introduces
this yeah that ends up looking a lot
like David and Haas package and cory jl
which is very much inspired by link
takes a lot from link it kind of looks
like a mutt right it's kind of like a
mix between link and deep liar I think
there are some nice things about it
there are some weird things about it but
I think it's the very least interesting
so this is what I like about it I like
that name rest well okay so yes I
mentioned is very much inspired by link
and queried al correo gels a package my
favorite aunt off that does stuff very
similar to what structured baristas and
I think he was inspired by a lot of very
powerful things in like that i would
like to incorporate so that's part of
what's driving the suggestion of this
interface I also kind of just like
hacking the deuce impacts I like that
notion so what are what are the
potential upsides well oh so it also
supports this kind of cute little inline
syntax right where you don't have to do
block you to say with table verb which
conceptually to me make sense so by the
way the question there is a question or
I think there should be a question it
probably is a question what the heck is
going on with is table of I so this
syntax is just introducing I is sort of
a token that represents an arbitrary row
in the data in the in your data an
arbitrary element of your data when
considered as an iterator you can refer
to in verbs that act element by element
so it's becoming a little bit more
general in terms of the
terms of what sorts of data sources it's
able to talk about because now you're
not talking about a data source in terms
of attributes or necessary not force
them to talking about a data source in
terms of attributes you can talk about
the data source as it's just an iterator
and I can talk about an arbitrary
element of this iterator so it produces
a craft as before and again this graph
contains everything that we need to
enact query or to collect queries over
the same so the graph is the thing and
then implementation follows it also so
again one of the advantages is that it
ties attributes to data sources it makes
whatever source and attribute is coming
from very clear and so this can be used
when you are say arcing filter clauses
or where clauses into joins so for
instance not you can say I have two
tables as my sources i assign the first
one is I robu token and the second one
this J Rho token and these are my filter
clauses yes so exactly so it's kind of
like using a single where clause and
sequel to filter and join and it
produces a graph that it reflects
precisely that question
right so the question is with this
syntax or could this impact support
window functions and my answer is it
could very well support it doesn't
current it doesn't currently but
actually if we go a few slides later so
this is just showing that you can I know
right fairly complicated filter causes
relatively complicated maybe not all
that complicated if you're a sequel
programmer in your like but they break
down into arguably something worthwhile
okay so advantages what advantages
precisely as I'm afraid I forget your
name well as political is asking about
window functions could it be used to
provide a syntax for window functions
and the answer is absolutely it could be
so for here for instance where we want
to restrict to all observations I from
IRS whose value for sepal length is
greater than you know the mean of I'm
not even bother writing it out but the
point is that you can refer to a window
using or good in theory refer to a
window are just using a regular
comprehension syntax thank you have a
good one
so just answer your question yes sure
actually I mean in principle sure I
haven't has to have for a rolling mean
right I would the thing that I
envisioned for that would be instead of
j dot sepal length for j in iris other i
would just do j Topsy pulling for j in
like i minus 52 I where I is this
presence index
of that of that like reference index
yeah
yeah so it would be it would refer to a
row in the iterator in this case just
the iterator over the rows of data frame
and then yes
I guess I guess there is a bit of slide
of him there would be a bit of sleight
of hand going on with that with with
that with that syntax we're in general i
means the refers to the row of the
iterator but then if you're using it and
say like a unit range it gets
interpreted as like the numeric index in
the current sorted order does that help
to answer the question thank you all
right oh you're welcome whatever I'm
supposed to say how am I on time okay a
little bit more time so those are some
of the advantages disadvantages there's
additional complexity you have to
specify these row token things
everywhere there's a little bit of
additional complexity for me the
developer there is a question of the
syntax why is my data source now a
function call that's weird what's going
on there who do you think you are and
then there's a bit of abuse four dots
for referencing a field name that could
be solved with name tuples that would be
nice if you had an iterator that just
produced named tuples than that could
just mean gatfield like it normally does
there is the name to call package I
thought about using it there's a fair
amount of meta programming involved in
getting that to work out correctly and
also i would like to not have to modify
global state in order to iterate over
something that would be nice but it's
definitely something that i've
considered or considered you know
rolling my own also so not dependent on
one more external package whose future i
don't i'm not sure of but yes there is a
name tuples package and it's pretty cool
Oh
I it's just TDL
it's referring to the current driver
yeah although then of course then of
course yeah of course then you lose
things like the window function syntax
and and and whatnot the other thing is
that arguably cheap you know TPL dot
attribute could could be taken to refer
to like the whole column so suppose so
one of the things I like about this i
dot syntax is that it provides you a way
of talking about the the current value
for a field as opposed to maybe
something like t be l dot attribute
where you talk about that a column as a
whole which you could use in you could
use and say an aggregate function yeah
so this yeah this is definitely innocent
it's a it's a good suggestion and that's
I'm and I'm happy for it so it's kind of
late and this the rest of us on this
talk was going to be about how data
frames is transitioning towards using
multiple arrays instead of data arrays
and the reason for this is precisely
because it is precisely that data arrays
do not provide type in for a whole
iteration they provide very not type in
for a rule actually I'm not very type on
in perl in dec iteration but they
provide marginally type unendurable
iteration and again if we're going to
make manipulation framework based on
iterating over a dataframe worth worth
while we need type invertible iteration
at very least the thing is that as soon
as you start building data frames on top
of multiple arrays you have no balls
flying everywhere and there's a host of
problems that you incur when you
introduce Nobles specifically that all
of your original methods that were
defying on allowable values no longer
work so you need to find some way of
making that work so the rest of the talk
was going to be about how such a
framework can be used to alleviate those
those concerns or just like ameliorate
that situation if people [ __ ] oh what's
that the punchline is that ok so the
punch line is that the punch line is
that ok we get method errors when we try
to use our normal functions on all
levels what do we do about this there
are a couple of things we could do one
you can just define all the methods
again right so we define x for Nobles
plus for Nobles to find all of your
favorite methods for notables and then
then it all works of course that's a lot
of methods to define and it's also it's
so it's not very general and you can
either continuously maintained a
collection of extended methods for now
levels and every time somebody comes
across something that's not currently
supported and present method error you
add of lifted definition into this
repository of lifted at the definitions
here I'm using the word lifted with
abandon belts Lane it later on so you
could do that there also you can also
define the core subsets like a corset of
lifting method definitions and then hope
that everything else is defined
generically and can generically rely on
those core subset of lifted methods when
I say lifted methods i just mean that
it's there defined over notables and
will do what you want them to do ie
return nullable of the value you expect
when the arguments are not null and
return null when you are
to our know so you could do that you
could also define a higher order
function call it lifts which takes any
function and any arguments be available
or not knowable and does the right thing
with them so this is more general and it
can be made performant now that we have
high performance or now that anonymous
functions are functions passed as
arguments our performance in Julia 0.5
we can make this performance its general
you can give proper syntax or proper
semantics of things like three-volume
logic with it the downside is that you
have to write lift everywhere which is
you know arguably really good practice
if you're a statistician and you want to
be explicit about how you're handling
little values and it's a real pain in
the ass for everything else and arguably
I mean there's a case we made that okay
if you're doing an analysis then you
should you know v8 to be explicit about
how you're handling null values but if
you're just doing manipulations of your
data you should be able to rely on
transformations that can handle null
values in a smart way because for the
most part the rules pretty clear if
arguments are null return null if not
return what you'd expect okay so we have
the two strategies one of them seems a
lot like the vectorization problem that
we had with vectorized functions and
Julia that was solved within efficient
broadcasting syntax the other strategy
use a higher order function that's
really cumbersome to write so my point
is the punch line is that okay if we're
using macros to provide a query
manipulation query framework and these
meant these macros manipulates user
expression any way we can use them to
transform the call graph of any user
specified functions to just lift
everything transform f of X is to lift f
of X
everywhere so that's the thing we can do
it has some drawbacks because for
instance you have you might have
functions that have non-standard lifting
semantics like three valued logic and
since this is a purely syntactic
transformation only operators that are
visible to the macro performing that
transformation can be transformed so for
instance if you have this very simple
data frame like this and wait a minute
which is ok you have a simple data frame
like this the macro can see this
operator so it can transform it into
lift of or a comma B and that will give
you the proper three value logic
semantics but then if you were to do
something like this f of x y equals x or
y and then do this user define and then
filter by this user defined function it
gives you something different because
the macro can't look inside of the
definition of f and see that you've used
this thing that has a non-standard
lifting semantics it just sees ok f
apply standard lifting semantics to that
and that gives you a different result
which is not ideal that's kind of a kind
of a Gaussian could be problematic you
could just make this really really
explicit in bold letters at the top of
the package if you're going to rely on
three valued logic explicitly ass all
such operators to the macro so the point
is that this is a thing we can do to
make multiples more useful there are
there is no perfect solution I don't
think except for one that might not eat
people which is to basically if you have
a function called on argument signature
where any of the arguments are nullable
or of a pipe similar to nullable that we
decide all to propagate knowles
automatically then the cup then whatever
code lowering mechanism
exactly she's just lower to lift f of
lift f / arguments and so that would not
be a matter of dispatch it would just be
a matter of cogeneration I have no idea
this is feasible I was really hoping
somebody would be here today who could
tell me I did this is feasible I will
take a lot of work or this is totally
unfeasible and you should just forget it
so if anybody has strong feelings about
this I'd love to hear it but anyway so
that's that's the hmm yeah exactly
exactly so that's ultimately the punch
line about nobles is that we kind of e
them for generating efficient iterative
code and we don't really know how to
make them usable in a gin in a general
extensible and user-friendly way but
we're working on it and I think we're
making progress
from I very very very limited so the
question is are you trying to just use
monads and what is that's not quite the
question
yeah so yes I would agree with that in
supporting inspires of a very limited
understanding of monads are I will agree
that basically like basically we have
this set of functionality defined on a
certain domain and there's this parallel
universe where the functionality is
systematically or we want the
functionality the parallel University
systematically derived from the
functionality in the base universe which
I kind of is sounds like that that's
that's kind of what monads do okay so
that's that's the situation and yes
basically we don't really know what what
aspects of the language will best be
able to handle this it's not yet clear
this is a joke about writing you know or
we could just forget about Nell balls
altogether we could wait for somebody to
special case small union types to be
that make the performance or we could
just go back to data arrays and write
code like broadcast for data arrays
which just uses heroic amounts
metaprogramming to achieve type
stability which I don't recommend
there's some final thoughts I the trend
seems to be go moving towards
domain-specific language is built out of
macros and other other parts of the
Julia programming language that will
help us with data management simulation
modeling visualization etc this is not
entirely new you have packages
especially modeling packages for
probabilistic programming already that
and also for mathematical modeling or
yeah mathematical programming like jump
that are really effective so this seems
to be something that Julie is good at
and so probably will see more of it in
the future as a statistician I would
really like to see something like this
for simulations I think that would be a
really cool thing and would be really
composable with a our ebay or dsl for
data manipulation and then visualization
and modeling and whatnot
these packages along with data streams
abstract tables and also now SATs models
sasha l are really stripping away a lot
of like what data frames was originally
built with which is and and kind of
coming to a court notion of what it
means to be a tabular data store a
tabular data source in Julia it seems
like the most important thing is you are
a map from fields two columns that you
can iterate over and produce fuels which
is pretty I mean that's fairly
straightforward but now I think we're
getting to the point where having having
found that we can now begin to make a
lot more things generic and more
powerful and finally I I feel like I see
ouch expressed about data frames and
Julia statistical computing in general
that I can entirely understand right it
took a while for you know data frames to
get to a certain point and you had John
models white writing things like why
data frames are still slow you know
years later I think there's reason for
optimism I'm hopeful for the future I
think that the people who are doing work
now are on the right track and that's
not just you know what I've handing
myself or whatever I think are people
who are working on the stuff of a really
good ideas and I'm excited for what they
bring and I'm not an official voice so
don't take this as gospel but I think
the the people behind the Julius has
community day difference what not are
hoping to put release this new version
of data frames built on top available
arrays sometime early next year and I'd
like to plan a more solid release of
this package that I've been working on
to coincide with that so finally
that's kind of funny I forgot to change
code from code to mark down I'm very
grateful to that supposed to be a header
John miles wide at Facebook who is my
mentor for this project over the summer
who was my metric for a nullable raise
project the previous summer and who has
been really generous with his time with
me and from whom I've learned a lot of
very worthwhile things lesioning at MIT
who had who helped me a lot and thinking
through this population structure
interfacing is also writing sequel
translation for it and actually getting
that off the ground I'm very grateful to
Alan Gilman and rural Shaw who arranged
this opportunity for me to work at MIT
over the summer I'm super grateful for
the people at Julia Central who were
very patient with my very noobish
questions and I'm grateful to Spencer
and for inviting me out here if we all
for showing up ebay for hosting I
thought I didn't I didn't write down but
i'm also really grateful to milan for
holding malleable arrays together while
I clouded in graduate school and drowned
in the sea of work and barely kept on
track with that so Milan is doing a lot
of work to old data frames and the
surrounding functionality together and
he deserves a shout out so thank you all
yeah so I understand we have five
minutes for questions
yeah so kind of both I feel like I've
had a lot of really productive back and
forth with David we're like each point
out issues with basically I think we
agree on a lot of things and the
packages that we're developing are very
similar I think his is definitely more
mature than line and he recognized the
power of a link like functionality more
earlier on and seized on that and I'm
definitely now just catching up to draw
inspiration from that I think the main
thing where we differ is our thoughts on
lifting the holes nullable strategy so
David is pursuing the method extension
approach and I'm pursuing more this
higher order lifting approach it's not
really clear which one is ultimately
going to be better I really don't know I
have my reasons for preferring the
higher order lifting approach but I
think it's on the whole good thing you
have two people doing otherwise similar
things but trying out these two
different approaches and we can have
more you know not quite a controlled
experiment but hopefully we'll get some
data you know in the coming year to
really see which one is then if not
better than less problematic and yeah I
kind of do feel in competition with that
I'm like I just yeah definitely yeah
all right thank you
I'm so mic'd up yeah it's awesome thank
you